hello everyone as the title suggests
this is one of the weirdest stories
regarding chest you will ever hear the
game is from a very strong tournament in
Lone Pine in California from 1979 and it
was it was an extremely strong
tournament 73 players they awarded two
brilliancy prizes after each round now I
don't know if they agreed that they were
just award - brilliant surprises or two
brilliant games were played in every
round either way it sounds like a great
tournament and the tournament the
director for this event was the one and
only Isaac cash Don I don't know if
you've seen cars Nancy mortal and my
channel if you haven't I suggest you
check it out I will put a link to it in
the description below and here we have a
resin double eNOS with the white pieces
against the Jeremy's Suleman wood the
black pieces a lot of you who probably
read about chess and you know have some
chess books chances are you have a book
by Jeremy Suleiman as he's a very
successful author and he's the same
Jeremy summon if you've seen my video on
the Harry Potter movie had that composed
the chess game that was used in Harry
Potter the Philosopher's Stone and as he
says he didn't even get credits for it
in the movie but the guy that brought
two donuts under said he he got some
credits so that that aside or acceptable
illness was considered to be the
strongest Asian Grandmaster he's from
the Philippines and he was considered to
be the strongest Asian Grandmaster until
you haenyeo Toure I took his place so
definitely a strong match and Jeremy
summoned he is an international master
although I don't know if he was an
international master at the time this
game was played in a way he says he was
very happy about facing a grandmaster
and he wrote an article about this game
and some other games as well I will put
a link to that as well in the
description below be sure to check out
the entire article as he also covers a
game where he plays against the drunk
Grandmaster I think I'll probably cover
that game as well on my channel so be
sure to check that out as well
now let's see the game and what this
story is actually about chess is a very
logical game but chess players are often
illogical
you know chess players are always trying
to get an edge over their opponent
whether it's psychological physical
environmental some players enjoyed
smoking on the board some player
smoked bad cigars you know with really
bad smell simply to annoy their
opponents rule Lopez you all know who
rule opposites you probably played his
openings all the time he often plays the
board so the Sun would actually hit his
opponent in the eyes so players were
always trying out different kinds of
things
Alexander alley action for example he
had a Siamese cat and he would place his
cat on a chess board before the game to
bring him luck and secretly he was also
hoping for an allergic reaction from his
opponent and after some time they said
that he couldn't do that so then he got
a sweater with a picture of his cat on
it so a lot of chess players were really
superstitious and illogical but this
game rescinded Bolinas I really took
things too far and it's unclear why he
did it so let's let's see this game
resemble Bolinas has the white pieces
and this is a game from round three and
opens up with C for the English opening
we have C 5 the symmetrical variation at
Knight to f3 Knight f6 Knight to c3 and
D 5 the three Knights variation C
capture some d5 Knight captor son be
file and the G 3G six Bishop to G to
Bishop to g7 and we have castles by both
sides and Queen to b3 by Bolinas we have
Knight to c7 avoiding the exchange the
knight is attacked twice and the white
doesn't want a black doesn't want to
capture on c3 after B captures on c3
white can white conform a very nice
Center after playing III and d4 so here
Sillman retreats with the night and
night to c7 we have d3 and Knight to c6
and it is at the disposition that this
weird story begins as Jeremy summoned
says in the article in this position or
acceptable Ennis took out took well I
don't know if he took it from the table
or from where a big jar a big thermos
bottle of hot tea and then he then he
grabbed a jar of honey and then Simon
thought that he would pour the tea
that he would put pour the honey into
the tea but actually he poured the tea
into the honey jar and that that became
like a really dense gooey liquid and he
drank the entire honey jar and someone
says that after he drank that that his
eyes simply had this weird glare to them
probably after all of that sugar hit his
brain and in this position he smiled at
Silman and he played Knight to a4 and
already you can see this is a very very
weird move probably sugar sure has a
very very weird effect on the brain
especially if you take a lot of it I did
have some honey before making this video
probably I thought maybe I could
understand Bolinas moves a bit better we
have B 6 a normal response protecting
the c5 pawn preparing the ship - b7 we
have Bishop to g5 also not a very clear
move and a similar response with Bishop
to g4 we have rook F to e 1 and now nice
to e6 attacking the bishop and g5 bishop
comes back to e3 and here we have Bishop
captures on f3 and E captures on f3 if
Bishop captures on f3 it doesn't really
change anything then Knight e to d4
comes attacking the Queen and the bishop
after Bishop captures Knight captures
and Queen to d1 still black will capture
the bishop he captures on f3 and hear
something like Queen to d7 can be played
and then you have this weak d3 pawn you
have this f3 point you'd have the weird
night on a4 it's a much better position
for black Plus you have this amazing
Bishop on g7 so after this Bishop to f3
he captures on f3 was played and now
Knight e to d4 and it was in this
position
Silman looked at his opponent and he
said that he was so out of it that he he
wouldn't be surprised if Bolinas passed
out here and here he played Queen to d1
we have Knights the b4 and here you can
see black might be threatening night to
c2 and probably with all that sugar in
his brain Bolinas thought that this was
the actual
tonight the situ so he played a three
and probably probably to provoke night
to see to because now if you play night
to see to simply Bishop captures on d4
and now you can't capture the rook if
you capture the rook simply Bishop
captures on g7 King captures and Queen
captures Knight an a.1 so after this
Bishop captures and before someone would
have to recapture the bishop and now
Knight to c3 and black is still better
but maybe white can hold this after f4
he will have a nice Bishop ng to maybe
he could hold this but after this a
three move here that Balan has played he
actually missed the real threat Jeremy
was planning and that's nice characters
on v3 and now white is falling apart you
of course you can't capture the night if
you capture the night then you get
Knight captures an f3 this is with check
after you capture you lose the Queen so
after this night to d3 Bishop captures
on d4 was played and again Bishop
captures on d4 again you can't capture
the night now if you capture it and
Bishop captures on f2 with the same idea
you lose the Queen so after Bishop to d4
Bolinas played rook to e2 here we have
b5 attacking this night Knight to c3 and
now Knight capture some b2 attacking the
Queen and now the knight on c3 is
undefended and it's simply a terrible
position for White Queen to c2
we have Knight to a4 now pinning this
night this night but also the knight is
attacked twice there's no way to defend
it and here probably capturing the night
on a4 is the best move but doesn't
matter what white place it's simply a
losing position Bolinas play Knight
captures on b5 here rope was captured
Bishop captures rook on a1 and after
Queen captures on a for Jeremy someone
played a 6 and in this position Rosendo
Bolinas resigned the game as the knight
is trapped as you can see
rook is covering a7 Queen c7 the point
is covering d6 also this point is
covering d4
Bishop is covering c3 there are no
squares available for this night he
loses the night and resigns the game so
it's a very very
weird move the whole tea and honey jar I
don't know what the purpose of it was I
don't know if Ross and Elena's thought
that all that sugar would take his brain
into some kind of an overdrive and he
would play a brilliant game or something
or was it simply to you know psych out
Jeremy Solman in a way it didn't have
the effect that bully must wanted it to
have and I don't know if he only used
this maneuver in this game but he could
he might have used it in all of his
games as out of all the 73 players
he finished the tournament in 17th place
so only three players were worse than
him in this tournament he finished with
two and a half out of nine points so
definitely definitely a weird maneuver
and in the weird story not not like
something you hear every day also
someone says if you will read art the
article that Bolinas got his revenge
some years later when he played a game
against sillman when sylvan wasn't
feeling that great so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed this game and
I do hope you enjoyed this story I hope
you're all having a great Saturday thank
you all for watching
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I will make one of the
videos card Nancy mortal game for those
of you who haven't seen it do check it
out it's it's an amazing masterpiece I
would like to thank a test merchant
Laurence Cuthbert gunner Wolff a young
cygwin son Austin Wilson and Anthony
Reyes for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon